do you miss Call of Duty's early years
set in the ravaged battlegrounds of
world war two well then you'll be happy
to hear that the series is headed back
to the classic setting in this year's
game I'm Matt and this GameSpot news
update is coming to you from a time
machine Activision has confirmed that
Call of Duty World War two is launching
this year
unfortunately none of the footage we're
showing is from the actual game because
as of this video Activision has only
released this image the only things we
know about the game are its title
developer and when we'll see an official
reveal sledgehammer games is on deck
this year and as someone who loved its
previous game advanced warfare
I'm really interested in seeing what
they can do with the classic setting the
official worldwide reveal kicks off on
April 26th at 10 a.m. Pacific so make
sure to LIKE and subscribe to be one of
the first to see that Call of Duty World
War two brings us back to a setting that
the series has quite the history with
every Call of Duty game before modern
warfare took place during World War two
and after 2008 world at war the entire
series committed itself to modern and
futuristic settings we'll keep you
updated as we learn more about the new
Call of Duty but if you want more
historical combat and action check out
our video on every new weapon and tank
in battlefield ones latest expansion